skin care can be complicated with so
many steps with pearl Skin studio the
sponsors of the segment they are back to
show us they're making skin care easier
with the basic skin health system and
thank you for this because I am one who
is very overwhelmed with all the
different steps yes you got makeup you
got sunscreen you got skin care and just
everything you know I need just to keep
it simple if you guys can help with that
yeah for sure you guys keep watching if
you want to do all of it in one step in
three minutes look fabulous keep
watching because we're going to start
with makeup skincare and all-in-one all
in one Olive science I'm constant I'm
concentrating color science basic skin
Health System okay we'll prove it to you
right now it's very easy to apply it's
still falling down it's a foundation
Flex
uh face shield it has color it has
physical sunscreen SPF 50 protects from
all of the Rays and looks glowy look
very natural it looks like skin and
that's what we're looking for right
heavy cakey yeah yeah so right now she's
using one product that has three in it
so it's a eye cream concealer and
sunscreen this little tool is so easy to
apply metal tool keeps your eyes
de-puffed because it stays cold so and
you can apply it and blend it with it
amazing SPF 35 now she's applying SPF 50
powder brush it's a fish flying
sunscreen with a brush yes also it can
be a highlighter because it has a glow
in it and it's great to keep it in your
purse to reapply sunscreen because you
have to reapply sunscreen every two
three hours amen so this product stays
on your bath counter okay this product
stays in your purse this has been great
this is amazing okay look at her
Flawless face wow and that was so quick
for people like me on TV or whatever you
have to be ready every day we need that
so how do you know which products work
for your type of skin though so these
products the most amazing products
because they work for every skin type
okay conditioner acne dry oily lip shine
that she's just applied has hyaluronica
sunscreen as well
and they get it free with the purchase
of three products which is facial cream
powder and concealer wow did you guys
hear that special I'll repeat it okay
now what about this is not just
obviously we have a beautiful woman
displaying these products but these are
not just for women they're for the
entire family yes correct me because
it's physical sunscreen no chemicals
zinc and titanium men like use brush
because it's not greasy it can be used
on the ears on both heads kids love it
because it's fun they feel like they're
applying makeup yeah and don't be afraid
of the brush okay yes because it's color
less some of the brushes are colorless
some brushes has color some brushes have
glow in it so it's for everyone that's
incredible you look so good that's
amazing obviously because you saw you
know it comes in every shade yeah I love
it thank you so much
you're welcome thank you to Pro Skin
studio for sponsoring this segment all
you got to do is call
702-525-5504 or visit
pearlskinstudio.com again that special
offer purchase all four of those color
science products you just saw from
today's segment and receive a free color
science lip gloss that is a value of 39
Kindle